let's go girls
a plunging black velvet gown a wild
leopard print cowboy hat and matching
thigh-high boots shania rocks the red
carpet at the 15th annual academy of
country music honors the best-selling
female country music artist of all time
is the queen of the night as she
received the poet's award for her
contributions to country music
i started writing music songs when i was
10. and my biggest joy instead of
playing with dolls i was playing with
words this was a game to me almost it
was a really fun challenging way to play
and it was also great escapism
i love to read but i prefer to write
and it was a canadian takeover of music
city as avril lavigne presented shania
with her award let's go girls the pop
princess channeled her inner twain as
she stunned in leopard print and i throw
back to shania's hooded outfit in don't
impress me much but the tributes didn't
stop there kelsey bellerini wore this
stunning floor-length white turtleneck
gown and if it looks familiar it should
as it's the same dress shania wore to
the 1999 grammys we got it out of the
grammy museum 24 hours ago um we just
had our fingers crossed that it would
fit because obviously we would not alter
our thing about it um and it did and so
it's another way that i get to like
honor her tonight and her legacy oh my
god
kelsea
it's like the dress came back alive
again
through her
and
it's just wonderful it's a huge
compliment and just great to see it
dusted off and have that energy back
into it again
[Music]